imaginez vous vous réveillez un beau
jour on peut être nui est une créature
malveillante est assise sur votre
poitrine elle vous empêche de respirer
et elle vous regarde suffoquer d'un air
creux pire vous ne pouvez pas vous
défendre puisque vous vous rendez très
vite compte que votre corps complètement
paralysé et quand vous essayez de crier
pour appeler au secours aucun son ne
sort de votre poche terrifiant à cette
horreur qu'on croirait tout droit sorti
d'un film du même nom ça existe vraiment
c'est bien réel et ça s'appelle
la paralysie du sommeil c'est un trouble
du sommeil bien particulier alors je
vais pas commencer à spoiler mais un des
premiers trucs qu'on peut faire quand on
a ce genre de troubles c'est d'améliorer
la qualité de son sommeil et je vais
vous raconter tout ça après mais la base
c'est d'avoir une bonne literie c'est la
raison pour laquelle je me suis associé
à emma
non
non plus en
voilà je me suis associé à emma donc
c'est un site qui vend des sommiers des
matelas des surmatelas des oreillers du
linge de lit etc et sponsorise cette
vidéo et je vais même vous offrir une
réduction mais jouera comme ça après
leur truc à eux c'est proposer des
produits qui améliorent la qualité du
sommeil justement en utilisant
différentes technologies comme la
mémoire de forme par exemple d'ailleurs
leur matelas hybride a été élu meilleur
choix ufc que choisir en 2021 pour
l'instant moi j'ai juste les oreilles à
mémoire de forme et la couette en
microfibre terme aurait dû la triste
mais c'est déjà acheminé à regarder
voilà c'est moi qui dort un bébé un
poupon je désespère pas de pouvoir
tester leur surmatelas bientôt mais déjà
je peux vous dire deux trois trucs en
attendant de vous parler de la réduction
d'abord ces livrets super vite moi j'ai
reçu ma commande en 72 heures et puis
c'est vachement bien emballé ça prend
pas beaucoup de place et les cartons
sont faciles à ouvrir en plus d'être
rapide la livraison elle est gratuite et
le retour éventuellement aussi parce que
vous avez s'ennuie décès sans risque en
gros ça veut dire que si au bout de
trois mois vous n'êtes pas convaincus a
voulu renvoyer sans payer et les matelas
sont garantis 10 ans et pour en revenir
à tout ce qui est sonnants et
trébuchants vous avez 40 % de réduction
sur le site français et sur le site
belge car j'adore la belgique et les
belges ça c'est en temps normal mais
s'il ya déjà des promos genre du 14 au
20 mars il ya déjà jusqu'à 50% de
réduction avec le code vous avez -10% en
plus des promos et tout ça en passant
commande avec le code
[Musique]
l'été c'est
si vous voulez vous pouvez aussi passer
directement par le lien que je vous ai
mis en discussion voilà et c'est l'abc
mois à partir de la date à laquelle est
sorti cette vidéo dont vous avez jusqu'à
septembre 2022 pour en profiter donc
allez faire un tour sur leur site je
vous mets liens dans la description et
si vous voulez acheter un sommier un
matelas sur matelas un oreiller du linge
de lit ou je sais pas quoi oubliez pas
le code dtc
[Musique]
l'extérieur on a l'impression que dormir
c'est pas très compliqué c'est genre
t'es réveillé hop tu dors up s'est
réveillé et ainsi de suite bon c'est pas
complètement faux c'est une façon
d'écrire de manière quand même très
vulgariser ce qu'on appelle l'alternance
veille sommeil qui est régie par le
rythme circadien le rythme de notre
horloge biologique si vous voulez dont
chaque cycle dure 24 heures on avait
déjà parlé de ça dans une vidéo sur le
sommeil j'ai par redétaillé parce que là
ici c'est pas complètement le sujet mais
si ça vous intéresse vous pouvez allez
voir je vous ai remis le lien dans la
description bref si on y regarde d'un
peu plus près le sommeil c'est un petit
peu plus complexe que ça et surtout vous
en doutez parfois ça se passe pas comme
prévu parfois la machine se dérègle et
on avait troubles du sommeil des
insomnies assez de sommeil des hypers
somme ni trop de sommeil ou des
parasomnie qui est un mot qui se la pète
un petit peu alors qu'en vrai il veut
juste dire qu'il nous arrive des trucs
chelous pendant qu'on adore ça aussi on
en avait déjà parlé dans une vidéo sur
les étranges maladie du sommeil pareil
je vous remets le lien si ça vous dit
parmi ces parasomnie y en a une qui se
trouve être celle qui nous intéresse
particulièrement aujourd'hui et qu'on va
détailler
la paralysie du sommeil oui oui il va
falloir suivre un petit peu vous vous
dormez ou quoi
[Musique]
le sommeil c'est une succession de
cycles
encore les cycles pour simplifier on va
dire entre quatre et six cycles par nuit
qui durent chacun environ une heure et
demie mais ça varie d'une personne à
l'autre à l'intérieur de ces cycles il
ya deux types de sommeil le sommeil lent
qui est d'abord léger et puis qui
devient profond et c'est à ce moment là
qu'on récupère de notre journée puis le
sommeil paradoxal pendant lequel on rêve
il représente à peu près un quart du
temps de sommeil total et c'est
précisément pendant ces phases de
sommeil paradoxal que les paralysies du
sommeil arrive donc on va s'attarder
dessus un petit peu et l'étudié point
par point pour comprendre pourquoi et
comment ça arrive cette histoire de
paralysie du sommeil le sommeil
paradoxal il a plusieurs
caractéristiques intéressantes
d'abord j'en ai déjà parlé c'est pendant
ces phases qu'on rêve donc notre cerveau
il est hyperactif par contre al'inverse
notre corps il est con vêtements inerte
parce que pour éviter qu'on fasse
n'importe quoi à cause de ce dont on est
en train de rêver nos muscles ils sont
paralysés et pour finir sachez que le
sommeil paradoxal on l'appelle aussi r e
m pas parce qu'on perd sa religion en
dormant mais pour rapid eye movement
mouvements oculaires rapides c'est pour
ça qu'on voit les globes oculaires
remuer sous les paupières de quelqu'un
qui est en train de rêver si on le
regarde dormir n'est déjà fait ça on en
sait un peu creepy mais c'est instructif
vous allez comprendre après pourquoi oui
je ménage mais effet dacquois dans un
monde idéal on enchaîne les phases de
sommeil lent léger lent profond
paradoxal et a pour part pour un tour
lent léger lent profond paradoxal et
c'est ça quatre à six fois par nuit et à
la fin on se réveille le soleil vient de
se lever encore une belle journée il va
bientôt arriver sauf que des fois ça ne
se passe pas comme ça parfois en plein
pendant une phase de sommeil paradoxal
il ya un bug au niveau de nos cerveaux
normalement à ce moment là la zone de
notre cerveau qui gère l'état de
conscience donc l'éveil et la zone qui
gère les mouvements donc les muscles
elles fonctionnent en même temps elles
sont synchro si vous voulez et basse qui
crée ses situation de paralysie du
sommeil c'est une dissociation entre ces
deux zones qui sont plus raccord t ce
qui donne cette espèce de 3e et à un peu
hybride quelque part entre l'éveil et le
sommeil à savoir notre cerveau est
réveillé mais notre corps est encore
endormie ça donne le tableau donc j'ai
parlé ans de lutte vidéo on est réveillé
on se rend compte de tout mais on peut
ni ni appeler à l'aide avec cette
angoisse de mort imminente et pas tout
le temps mais quand même souvent cette
impression d'une présence malveillantes
dans la pièce
autant vous dire que c'est pas fois pour
comprendre ce qui se passe il suffit de
reprendre les caractéristiques du
sommeil paradoxal dont je vous parlais
juste avant donc notre esprit est
réveillé mais pas notre corps on est
conscient mais vous vous souvenez en
phase de sommeil paradoxal tous nos
muscles sont complètement paralysé c'est
la raison pour laquelle on se rend
compte de tout ce qui se passe mais on
peut absolument pas bouger première
chose attention en réalité tous nos
muscles sont pas paralysés c'est
seulement ce qu'on contrôle
volontairement en temps normal ceux qui
sont responsables de nos mouvements ceux
qui sont chargés de nous maintenir en
vie comme le coeur ou les muscles
respiratoires par exemple eux ils
continuent à fonctionner de manière
autonome évidemment il fonctionne même à
fond parce que contrairement au sommeil
profond où tout tourne au ralenti en
phase de sommeil paradoxal tout
s'accélère et notamment la respiration
on respire très vite et pas forcément de
manière très régulière un peu comme
quand on fait une crise d'angoissé en
temps normal on s'en rend pas compte
mais la vue qu'on est à moitié réveiller
on s'en rend bien bien content c'est ce
qui donne cette impression
d'essoufflement voire de d'oppression ou
d'étouffement qui nous fait penser qu'on
va pas tarder à décéder et puis autre
type de muscles qui sont pas paralysés
ceux de nos yeux ou souvenez les fameux
rm les mouvements oculaires rapides
voilà nos yeux il fonctionne donc on
peut les ouvrir regarder partout autour
de nous et voir tout ce qui se passe et
puis dernière caractéristique du sommeil
paradoxal on rêve et comme je voulais
dit on est dans une espèce d'entre d'eux
me endormi me réveiller et notre cerveau
même s'il a conscience de tout ce qui se
passe et notamment qu'on est paralysé il
est quand même pas complètement réveillé
il est encore un peu en mode rêve et
vous savez comment ça marche quand on
rêve nos cerveaux il s'invente tout un
tas de scénarios plus ou moins what the
fuck autour de ce qu'ils nous titillent
psychologiquement pendant la journée et
particulièrement de ce qui nous angoisse
c'est un peu le concept de rêve eh bien
là c'est pareil on est paralysée on est
dans le mal on n'arrive pas à respirer
up sa part en délire mystique à base de
bestioles assise sur notre thorax ou de
monts qui nous guette mal dans un chrono
de chambre donc voilà c'est cet état qui
explique les hallucinations visuelles
auditives voir tactile qu'on peut avoir
dans ces cas là alors attention deux
choses importantes d'abord hockey une
paralysie du sommeil c'est hyper
impressionnant c'est angoissant on a
l'impression qu'on va y passer et tout
mais soyons très clairs c'est inoffensif
l'état physique dans lequel on s est le
même que celui dans lequel on est toutes
les nuits sauf que d'habitude mont d'or
donc on ne sait pas voilà donc on ne
meurt pas d'une paralysie du sommeil
c'est sans danger et puis un autre truc
ce bug de départ là celui qui fait qu'on
reprend conscience alors que notre corps
est encore en train de dormir non
seulement c'est pas grave mais en plus
c'est pas rare du tout une paralysie du
sommeil ça peut toucher n'importe qui et
on estime que sa touche 20% voire 40% de
la population mondiale parfois c'est
juste une fois et on en parle plus chez
d'autres c'est 2 3 fois dans la vie et
c'est tout mais chez certaines personnes
ça peut être plus fréquents et les
crises elles durent entre quelques
secondes et quelques minutes mais
croyez-moi quand on a l'impression qu'on
est en train de crever sa part l eau oui
je sais de quoi je parle bon donc on
sait comment ça marche maintenant mais
ce bug du cerveau il vient d'où bah on
sait pas vraiment pourquoi ça arrive
mais comme souvent dans ce genre de
situation on a identifié des trucs qui
font que ça arrive plus facilement on
appelle ça des facteurs favorisants
d'abord un sommeil de mauvaise qualité
ou le manque de sommeil ou des horaires
de sommeil irrégulier
ou les trois ans 8 des facteurs
psychologiques comme le stress un
traumatisme plus ou moins récents ou une
période de grande anxiété il ya aussi
certaines drogues et certains
médicaments qui favoriserait
l'apparition des crises et puis on parle
aussi de l'exposition à la lumière bleue
c'est à dire celle des écrans qui
perturberait la synthèse de la
mélatonine l'hormone du sommeil ces
emplois en reparler une prochaine fois
si vous voulez donc pour éviter que ça
arrivait bas il faut éliminer ces causes
en tout cas celle qui nous concerne ou
au moins commencer à travailler dessus
parce que c'est pas toujours si facile
mais en tout cas il faut déjà se poser
les bonnes questions alors tout ça c'est
du cas par cas c'est assez individuel
mais un truc concret quand même la
paralysie du sommeil c'est un truc
angoissant et quand on a tendance à en
faire on peut être stressé au moment
d'aller se coucher parce qu'on a peur
d'en faire justement et comme le stress
et l'anxiété ça favorise les crises
c'est le serpent qui se mord c'est un
peu comme avec les insomnies plus vous
stressé à l'idée d'en faire plus vous
risquez d'en faire donc un petit conseil
et ça en réalité c'est valable pour tout
le monde un sommeil de qualité ça se
prépare je vous en avais parlé dans la
vidéo que je vous ai remis en
descriptions il ya tout un tas de
conseils sur les trucs à faire et à ne
pas faire tout au long de la journée et
le soir venu pour un sommeil optimale
vous retournerez jeter un petit coup
d'oeil mais plus spécifiquement pour ce
qui nous intéresse là aujourd'hui l'idée
c'est d'être le plus détendu possible au
moment d'aller se coucher donc oui déjà
on évite les excitants que ce soit le
café le thé des médicaments des
activités physiques ou intellectuelles
la lumière bleue des écrans etc le soir
c'est pas le moment ensuite la pièce où
vous dormez pas trop chaude dans le noir
complet une bonne literie donc on l'a
dit au calme autant que possible
évidemment et puis le téléphone soit en
mode avion soit au moins sûr ne pas
déranger vous pouvez personnaliser les
réglages ccao tranquillise et puis
surtout n'hésitez pas une seconde à vous
trouver un petit rituel d'endormissement
relaxation autohypnose exercices de
respiration ce que vous voulez mais
quelque chose qui vous calme et qui vous
occupe l'esprit pour chasser les trucs
qui pourrait venir vous prendre la tête
de toute façon c'est pas le moment vous
allez dormir donc les trucs qui vous
prennent la tête vous pourrez rien y
faire aux arrêts ça demain bon super
mais si malgré tout ça ça arrive quand
même qu'est ce qu'on peut faire déjà
faut le savoir il n'y a pas de trucs
miracle et ça pour deux raisons d'abord
comme céline offensif c'est pas comme
s'il y avait eu des recherches de grande
ampleur sur la question et ensuite parce
que ce qui marche pour les uns marche
pas forcément pour les autres là encore
c'est assez personnel pour être concret
il ya deux écoles vous allez trouver des
gens qui vont vous conseillé d'essayer
de vous réveiller quand ça vous arrive
en plus des muscles oculaires il peut y
avoir d'autres petits muscles qui sont
pas complètement paralysé donc ya
certaines personnes qui conseille
d'essayer de bouger un doigt un orteil
où la langue en espérant que petit à
petit ça vous stimulent suffisamment
pour réveiller le reste de vos muscles
ou alors d'essayer de contrôler votre
respiration en se concentrant dessus
jusqu'à réussir à souffler très fort
voire à tous et où a parlé pour vous
réveiller toujours personnellement les
fois où ça m'est arrivé impossible de me
réveiller ça a été mieux à partir du
moment où je et lâché prise gerson bray
un petit peu dans le sommeil mon esprit
a rejoint mon corps si vous voulez et
puis les deux ont fini par se réveiller
en même temps voilà encore une fois faut
juste trouver le truc qui marche pour
soi mais bon il ya quand même pas mal de
gens qui disent que lutter pour se
réveiller déjà c'est assez épuisant et
puis en plus à force d'essayer sans y
arriver on risque d'aggraver les choses
en fait du coup validé ce serait plutôt
l'inversé un se calmer réussir à se
raisonner et se dire que 1 comme on l'a
déjà dit c'est sans danger donc on va
pas mourir 2 on est en train de rêver
cette bestiole qui fait sa toilette
assis sur notre thorax elle n'existe pas
vraiment 3 tout ça ça va s'arrêter quand
on se réveillera parce que encore une
fois oui on va finir par se réveiller 4
on n'arrive pas à bouger donc pas la
peine de forcer et 5 donc vu que le
problème c'est qu'on est à moitié
réveiller on va plutôt essayer de se
rendormir complètement comme ça le
décalage entre notre état de conscience
et l'état de notre corps il disparaît et
tout rentre dans l'ordre bon ok mais
comment on fait ça en pratique et oui
parce que c'est pas si facile il faut
avoir la lucidité de réussir à se dire
tout ça ça n'est pas réel je suis à
moitié endormi je suis en train de rêver
quand on arrive à faire ça on a fait
déjà une grosse partie du chemin mais
comment on arrive à faire ça justement
bas on se renseignant sur la paralysie
du sommeil de là pour comprendre comment
ça se passe pour savoir la reconnaître
et pour avoir tout ça bien en tête le
jour où ça arrive donc en s'informant et
là j'ai une bonne nouvelle c'est
exactement ce que vous êtes en train de
faire en ce moment-même donc bien joué
c'est déjà bien parti pour la première
étape ensuite une fois que vous avez
compris ce qui est en train de se passer
ce qui devrait faire baisser la panique
d'un bon cran déjà pour passer en notes
j'arrête de lutte et j'essaye de me
rendormir il ya plusieurs solutions qui
sont à peu près les mêmes options que
celle que vous avez pour vous aider à
vous endormir habituellement des
exercices de respiration ou de cohérence
cardiaque des trucs qui ressemble plus à
de la relaxation de la méditation comme
se visualiser dans un lieu et dans un
contexte apaisant etc il ya même des
gens qui disent qu'ils arrivent à
transformer une paralysie du sommeil en
rêve lucide un rêve lucide c'est une
espèce d'expérience au cours de laquelle
on sait qu'on est en train de rêver et
du coup on arrive à choisir ce dont on
va rêver j'avoue c'est tentant un
dernier truc avant de se quitter la
paralysie du sommeil on l'a vu c'est pas
dangereux dans la mesure où on n'en
meurt pas mais si ça arrive trop souvent
ça peut quand même finir par fatiguer ou
par avoir des répercussions sur le moral
et puis surtout c'est le signe qu'il ya
quand même quelque chose qui va pas et
que ça joue sur votre sommeil donc si ça
devient handicapant c'est comme pour
tout le reste il faut consulter avant
que ça devienne insupportable et comme
je suis sympa je vous mets dans la
description la liste des centres
spécialisés dans le sommeil voilà la
dtcc fini pour aujourd'hui on se
retrouve très vite pour de nouvelles
vidéos d'ici là prenez soin de vous et
prenez soin des autres mettez vous bien
et surtout portez vous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]